we really wanted to reach out to Joe
yeah yeah in a benign a nice kind way
everything that Islamophobic people are
angry about Islam with is founded
Judaism done we had a nice training hand
yeah with this hum do they love him
especially with your mashallah advanced
black belt skills of Exodus
you want protein go straight to the
source yeah because I mean we've got
someone who is actually of no who is
wearing your t-shirt I mean let's take a
look at this Oh have you guys met
Muhammad hijab well he's here with me
under Dean show I seller Malik oh that's
very interesting he's very wearing our
shirt he's wearing us actually my last
name on his shirt and one of his shows
and that's not Photoshop and he was not
going to actually put that t-shirt on
unless he done it strategically I don't
believe he's that kind of a haphazard
slapdash kind of human being so I think
it was it was a message and I think it
was a positive message so maybe we can
go through some of these videos so the
term radical Islam gets thrown around
right so radical Islam simply means I
really take my Islam seriously and now
this person who he brings on frequently
and pretty much says it pretty much if
you practice Islam that's what it
translates to you know you're pretty
much erratic these are I mean this stuff
is dangerous yeah is it
it's absolutely dangerous because if
people actually buy into this propaganda
then this will affect the life chances
of Muslims where people will now
compartmentalize the normal I will say
that the normative Muslim the Muslim who
is living by the Quran and Sunnah who is
Orthodox who is living by the tenets of
Islam and the injunctions of prescribed
by the Quran and Sunnah people will now
according to this who have no knowledge
will have no exposure to Islam see that
person as somewhat of a threat to their
way of living to their person to
actually to the actual person so without
evidence it is a statistical fact that
Muslims do not commit most acts of
terrorism domestically or globally it's
statistical you can't argue with its
objective research data that Muslims do
not
more than other faith groups and that
Muslims do not commit most terrorist
acts or mass shootings in the United
States however the way that a San
Bernardino is treated as opposed to a
Las Vegas puts us in a situation in
which we feel like at times we can't win
because we have to defend every lunatic
that takes one life or 16 lives whereas
other groups of people are given a pass
even when a person may be claiming their
faith or belong to their their group and
could murder 60 people without anyone
facing any repercussions for that and
our children have to bear the burden of
that if you think about how unjust that
is this kind of claim to be actually put
on air on a massive podcast like Joe
Rogan's podcast is to go to a very
irresponsible thing for Joe Rogan to
acquiesce to and to allow it to happen
on his podcast how can he make it right
he can make it right by every time there
is a claim like this by one of those
antagonists and I would call them
antagonists well people are anti Islam
first and foremost to ask them what the
evidence for that claim is and secondly
as you mentioned the beginning of this
show he has to now allow for Muslims to
be able to put the argument because he's
never had a Muslim Pro Islam Orthodox
Muslim on the show putting forward the
case for Islam and answering the
questions in the misconceptions you
ready to go it gives us the call
Muhammad he job and Eddie from the D
show we're coming with our guys Joe
let's do it let's go to the next one
this shirt actually looks good on Joe
doesn't it it does right it kind of
complements this physique yeah we can
get you another one Joe hopefully when
we come down when he invites Muhammad
hijab and myself will come down or or
you can write him we get you someone
else will come together and shout let's
go to the next one
God willing Joe Rogan he can go through
this also be a lot of fun for him as
well and many of his viewers let's go to
the first one and then we'll get your
comments on entry
you